all right so as the New York Manhattan
District Attorney's Office continues
there unhinged politically motivated
attacks on former president Donald Trump
there are many reports uh that district
attorney Alvin Bragg could be close to
indicting the 45th president now
president Trump's attorney is formally
requesting that the DA's office itself
be investigated because it has so
clearly been weaponized to Target a
single individual instead of being used
to prosecute all the actual crimes that
happen in New York every single day that
are ignored and Trump's attorney Joe
tacopena joins us now with much more uh
do you believe Joe we've known each
other a long time do you believe these
reports they're everywhere that they
expect this indictment are you expecting
it listen I I still hold out hope that
justice will prevail Sean because there
has to be and there is in fact a heavy
dose of disgust in the legal community
in the bar with prosecutors defense
attorneys judges that they're doing this
this is not what we do this legal system
has now been weaponized completely
weaponized and and you know you could
read that that idiot Mark pomeranz's
book
um who who violated all sort of grand
jury secretary laws had a fiduciary duty
to keep things confidential and instead
wrote a book and if you read his book he
even said it was amazing what he
admitted there that he was just looking
for a crime to fit the person and that's
not what we do it's not what we should
be doing and clearly here the Manhattan
District Attorney's office has stooped
to that level if they are looking at
this Stormy Daniels case because one
thing is clear that every single legal
scholar former members of the federal
election committee have opined that no
crime was committed here that there was
no campaign law violation at all
well let me ask you this there's an
article by msn.com and the headline is
Prosecuting Trump as Stormy Daniels
money would include hurdles according to
experts at one point
um they say if Bragg were to do this it
says it would be unusual for a state
prosecutor to use an alleged violation
of a federal law rather than of a state
campaign Finance law as it grounds to
elevate a false paperwork case from a
misdemeanor to a felony but it would
also be unusual to prosecute a
presidential candidate for violating a
state as opposed to Federal campaign
Finance laws do you believe that that
they're doing something this unusual
first of all do you believe it's unusual
on purpose for the purpose of elevating
what would otherwise be a misdemeanor
in New York to a felony
nationally yeah certainly clearly look
any prosecution in this matter would be
completely unprecedented meaning this
would be the first ever in the history
of this country and think about that
think of that statement let that roll
around your brain for a minute or two
campaign Finance laws of mercury to
begin with and and all the underlying
legal theories that they have here that
we've been hearing about from them had
these DA's office are untested
completely untested and have never been
utilized in this manner so there are
things here that I mean look at John
Edwards John Edwards which was a
completely different situation right you
had a third party paying for room and
board and rent to keep some some woman
that was pregnant with his child a
secret and that was a third party and in
fact actually happened here president
Trump has denied from day one having an
affair with this woman what he is is an
extortion victim and by the way it's
regardless of whether he did or didn't
he says he didn't I believe him and the
evidence I think is very powerful that
he never had an affair with her but more
importantly he's a victim of extortion
because she came out right before the
campaign and said well well the election
said unless you pay me I'm going to make
a public story about something that he
says is completely untrue so that's
something that would be done
irrespective here's the key it would be
done irrespective of the campaign
because as Michael Cohen the convicted
Purge or a liar a guy who has zero
credibility I don't even think he had a
law license quite frankly honestly what
he said when he pled guilty Sean in this
case was that the client his client was
doing it for to prevent personal
embarrassment and prevent embarrassment
to his family that takes it out of the
realm of exclusively campaign Finance
this is not campaign Finance location at
all let me go back I know you did an
interview with Stephanopoulos this
morning and he asked you three questions
if the president authorized the payment
to Stormy Daniels was the payment
properly recorded and was it connected
to the election and what I said yeah was
the only one that matters there is
number three because if it's not
connected to the campaign and then and
had the purpose of affecting the
election then one and two do not matter
at all at all it's not a crime nothing's
a crime so that's I'll go back to that
again this has to be tied to an election
and and more importantly the campaign
Finance laws and there's a critical
distinction separating campaign funds
from personal funds here this was all
personal funds let me ask you if I'm
hearing you right you're saying campaign
Finance laws are are not you know
etched in stone that there's some
somewhat ambiguous and the underlying
legal theories and this goes to the MSN
article uh are untested explain what
what they mean and what you mean by that
and that's other legal Scholars and
former members of the FEC have publicly
stated in the past about this sure I
have it written for me for the purposes
of influencing an election that's what
this has to be about solely for that
purpose not a primary purpose has to be
solely for the purpose of influencing an
election this payment right to this
Stormy Daniels so here is the statute's
prohibition on diverting campaign funds
for personal use and there's a reason
for that obviously you don't want people
who are donating money to a candidate to
all of a sudden have that candidate
spend money on his personal
um items um I mean anything in theory
could be to influence the campaign right
or the election I mean and you want to
campaign in a nice suit you don't want
to have a a 20 suit made in China that's
falling apart at the seams you want to
have a nice suit that expenditure in
theory according to this Theory could be
a campaign finance low violation of
course it's not so the crucial
distinction is separating campaign funds
from personal funds could you imagine
Sean where we'd be tonight if if
president Trump had used campaign funds
to make this payment oh my God they'd be
calling for his scalp instead he did
everything the right way he did nothing
wrong as he has said repeatedly and and
so spending campaign funds from personal
funds and separating those two is a
critical distinction here so personal
funds and personal funds use I'm looking
at the the statutes regarding this
spending news to fulfill any commitment
obligation or expense of a person that
would exist irrespective of the campaign
takes it out of the realm of what we're
talking about here of course of course
this would exist irrespective of a
campaign
all right Joe takapina he's the
president he's a lawyer for the
president of the United States President
45 Donald Trump uh will be following
this closely hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else